is there an
element of your world as doctors that
there are different religions because
if we put five doctors there they all
have fancy degrees they all could
believe in five different things
and they're all convincing so who do we
believe one minute do we go this round
of a diet one minute do we go that route
over that one minute we go
how what can we do as the consumer to
make sure we're being fed the right
advice
i think the best thing to do is use a
bit of common sense and you have to
think and you have to look through the
test of time
so if something has withstood the test
of time
then you know it's fairly decent advice
okay
so you look back at the 70s and i always
choose the 70s because this is a time
where there's not a lot of wide it's not
there's not widespread hunger in the
united states it's
you know it's fairly advanced i mean but
there's at the same time that there's
relative availability food there's no
obesity
and the question is why like what did
they do differently
then compared to what we're doing now
and of course
the big big change came in 1977
which was the change to eat a very low
fat diet
right so in 1977 the dietary guidelines
for americans came
out and all of a sudden all of us were
told
that we should eat less fat which was
the equivalent of telling people to eat
more refined carbohydrates so if you
look back at the first
food pyramid at the bottom of the
pyramid there's bread and there's rice
and there's potatoes
you know and it's like eat seven or
eight servings a day sort of thing right
seven to eleven i think serving today
and it's like who thinks eating seven
slices of white bread a day is slimming
like it's not it's not very slimming
because now we look back and say okay
well
you know eating a bunch of french fries
and potato chips and
you know bread is not very good and you
can say well those are all refined foods
as well but that's what was on the
pictures right it was what's the white
bread and so on
so you have to say okay well that was
one of the big changes that happened so
if we simply go back to a more
traditional way of eating
are we going to be able to sort of
regain this sort of effortless
uh maintenance of our weight and you'd
have to say well that's probably true so
this sort of
whole low-fat thing that came out of the
1970s
was the big change prior to that of
course people ate fat they eat cheese
they eat
eggs and all this sort of stuff and it's
interesting because again if you look
at the big scientific data of the time
in the 70s people ate three times a day
breakfast lunch and dinner
and by the 2004 when you look at the big
surveys
most americans were eating closer to six
times a day so
breakfast snack lunch snack dinner snack
so again big changes in both what we ate
and when we ate now they were related in
some sense that is people who are eating
a lot of refined carbohydrates you know
you eat
you know if you ate steak and eggs in
the morning you're pretty full until
lunch time if you ate
two slices of white bread and jam you're
sort of ravenous by 10 30 and looking
for a low-fat muffin
so people started eating much more
frequently so
the thing is that what i'm talking about
mostly is going to back to sort of a
1970s style diet which of course people
have been eating all the way prior to
that which is not a low-fat diet which
is basically eating
natural foods eating the fat like you
know this whole thing about
eating low fat cutting out the butter
and cutting out the cream and stuff
that didn't exist before 19 to 1970s
because people didn't care about that
stuff so much
and the you know eating fewer times in a
day cutting out the snacks and then
again if you wanted to lose weight then
you tried to
change either what you ate or when you
ate including the whole idea of fasting
which became a really dirty word
sometime
i think in the 1990s and uh
is because everybody started eating six
seven times a day and then you started
to hear the advice from dietitians oh
you should eat six small meals a day
it's like okay prior to 1970s
nobody ate six meals a day no at no
time in history did anybody eat six
times a day
right you think somebody in you know the
1500s you know
some monk who's busy all busy all day
praying and working the fields is gonna
have a snack and
you know bring out his granola bar he
didn't do that right
that wasn't something that we did so if
we start
introducing these sort of newfangled
diets like the low-fat diet like eating
six times a day
well those haven't stood the test of
time as opposed to eating
three meals a day natural foods and
if you want to sort of push it well you
can skip a meal because remember
in the 1970s if you were a naughty boy
you got sent to your bed without dinner
you basically fasted for 20 hours
from noon until the next day and nobody
died nobody
had any problems right it was fun yes
you're a little hungry and hopefully you
learned your lesson
but that was it that was it so if you
wanted to lose weight you could simply
change one of these levers and say you
know what i can fast
because if i don't eat what's going to
happen
well my body is going to be forced to
use the calories that have been stored
which is body fat that's perfect
so then you say okay we're all fasting
that's interesting is it
a newfangled idea no
it's only been done since the beginning
of time and i mean you look at the bible
you look at the
you know christianity judaism buddhism
hinduism you know no question yeah
everybody has fasting right the greek
orthodox church
mormonism everybody fast so it's not
something that people can't do
it's been proven over and over and over
that they can do it
and what's interesting is that up to
that point
it's considered up to the 80s and 90s
considered very healthy practice
even when there's no obesity people are
like yeah it's a great thing you cleanse
out your body you feel great
right it's not super fun but it's it's
there for you
right in ramadan you have a month of
fasting
so and then after the 1990s it just
falls off like everybody thinks it's
like the worst thing you can possibly
do to your body even if you're 400
pounds
i'm like what do you think body fat
is there for it's there for you to use
as a source of energy
if you have nothing to eat so if you're
fasting
you're basically feeding yourself
through your own body fat
which is literally the reason we have
body fat
it's not there for looks is there for
you to use
if you have nothing else